in the last video i kind of i gave a
little bit of a hand wavy explanation
about why s waves don't travel in liquid
or air and what i want to do in this
video is give you a little bit more
intuitive understanding of that and
really go down to the molecular level so
let's draw a solid
so let's draw a solid and it has nice
it has nice covalent bonds strong bonds
between the different molecules and the
bonds are drawn by these lines in
between so if i were to hit if i were to
hit this solid you know this really
small hammer where i just hit at a
molecular level but if i were to hit
these molecules
if i were to hit these molecules hard
enough that they move but not so hard
enough that it breaks the bonds then in
the next then essentially what it's
going to look like is these this kind of
row of molecules are going to move to
the left so you're going to have that
row of molecules moving to the left and
then the row above it won't fully move
to the left just yet but it will start
to get pulled so let me just draw all of
the bonds i'm just drawing all the same
bonds because these are strong bonds
that we have in a solid because these
are strong bonds actually they could be
ionic bonds as well because they are
strong bonds that we have in this solid
they'll essentially be pulled they'll be
pulled in the direction the top row will
be pulled in the direction of the bottom
row and then the bottom row and so
they'll start kind of moving in that
direction and then the bottom row will
essentially recoil back and then you
fast forward a little bit and so then
the top row will have moved to the left
and now the the bottom row will start to
move back
and then the
the bottom row will start to kind of
move back especially because remember
it's bonded it's bonded to other things
down here it's bonded to more of the
solid down here so to move back and you
can see this transverse wave you can see
this s wave propagating essentially
right over here the s wave the kind of
peak of the s wave is here now it has
moved up now let's think about the exact
same situation with the liquids in
liquids you don't have these strong
ionic or covalent bonds between the
different molecules you just have these
weak kind of bonds usually formed due to
polarity so you in the liquid
that's you know water is a good example
you just have these kind of weaker bonds
formed because of because water is a
polar molecule so this the kind of
halfway polar sides or the halfway
positive sides are somewhat attracted to
the halfway negative sides so they kind
of
flow past each other but if i were to
hit
these water molecules right here with my
hammer what would happen
well they're definitely going to they're
going to start moving to the left and
they're actually you know this one's
going to put bump into that one which is
going to bump into that which is going
to bump into that one they're going to
move to the left
so they're going to move to the left
but these molecules aren't going to move
with them it's essentially going to you
could view it as going to break that
very weak bond due to polarity they're
going to move away from each other
they're essentially let me draw this
these top molecules in green they're
essentially just going to flow past each
other they're going to flow past each
other and this guy might have had also
weak bonds with stuff below it too i
should draw just dotted lines
with stuff below it too but because of
because of the the the impact here these
guys are just going to flow they're
actually going to compress in this
direction you're going to have a p wave
a compression wave going this direction
where this one bumps into that one and
then goes back and then this one bumps
into that one and goes back and this one
bumps into that one but there's the
bonds aren't strong enough the bonds and
it's even more the case with air but the
bonds aren't strong enough for these
blue guys to take these green guys for
ride and the bonds are also not strong
enough for the guys
for the adjacent molecules to kind of
help these blue guys to retract to their
original position so when i talked about
the elasticity in the last video that's
what i was talking about there's no the
bonds aren't strong enough to cause the
things that have deformed to kind of
move back to where they were and also
their bonds aren't strong enough to
allow the things that are deformed to
pull other things with it and so that's
why in general s waves don't trap they
only travel in solid and they won't
travel in liquid or air